- One of the skills
that you need to pick up very quickly
as a consultant is project management.
As a consultant,
you regularly work in large organizations
on topics, covering many
functions and business units.
It is the responsibility
of the project lead
in the consulting team to set
up a governance structure,
to set up some project
management best practices,
to make sure that the
whole team stays organized
and can deliver on the things
that the team needs to deliver on.
Hi guys, welcome to another coffee break
here on my channel Firm Learning.
My name is Heinrich and on
this channel I want to help you
to become successful.
In the first years of your career.
In today's video,
I'm going to show you in detail,
how at MBB consulting firms,
the consultants keep the
whole project organized,
how they organize their shared drives,
how they archive and make files
available to the whole team.
Before we jump in to the video,
I wanna take an opportunity
to say thank you to all the
sponsors of this channel.
You're really helping me to
bring this channel alive.
This is much appreciated.
If you wanna become a member as well
and get access to some great perks,
sign up via the join button below.
There's also a link in
the video description.
It would mean the world to me,
if you become a member of this channel,
but now let's jump into the topic.
And how do consultants stay organized.
Consulting firms usually use
some type of shared
drive service provider.
So whether it's Box, Dropbox, OneDrive
or anything related,
there's going to be a platform
where all your files for a
project are going to stay.
So let's start with
the overarching folder.
How do you name it?
And here a beginner
mistake that some people do
is that they name the folder
the same as the client's name.
So they give the folder
the name of the company
that you are currently working for.
Here the big risks that you want to avoid
is that at some point
you are sitting together
in a meeting with clients.
Now your screen is shared
and you need to pull out a file
and now your Explorer pops up.
And now there's a list of all the folders
with all that your client names
that you're currently working for
or you worked for in the past.
Of course, this would be a
major breach of confidentiality.
You do not reveal your client
names to other companies.
So make sure that your client folders
for your overarching folder structure
are not named in the company way
but give it some kind
of a more cryptic name,
somewhat corrupting abbreviation
that you use internally
so that if your Explorer window pops up
in front of a client,
that all your client
names are not revealed.
So how do you organize and
structure the next level of data
within your folder?
And now I'm going to show
you a typical structure
and I used variations of that many times.
Of course, the details
can always depend a bit
on the needs of the individual projects.
But if you follow this,
usually this would be already
a very solid structure.
So first of all,
you will see that on the
left of each sub folder,
you use numbers to keep
them in the right order.
If you just give them a name,
then they will usually be
ordered alphabetically.
And then this can be a mess
because often of course the best order
is not the alphabet but
another order that you define.
So give numbers and use
at least two digits,
because often you will
have more than 10 folders.
So use numbers to make sure
that the folder always stay
in the order that you want them to stay.
So what would be typical folders
that you'd like to have
on this first level?
So often I'd like to start
with an admin folder.
So this is the folder
where you put all kinds
of admin documents.
And so for instance,
time sheets for your team,
maybe some other overview,
so that everybody needs access to,
some travel information,
just admin documents,
where everybody needs to
have an easy access on it.
Next you set up two different
types of meeting folders,
one for internal meetings
and one for client meetings.
So in the internal meeting folder
you then archive all the
meetings that you have
with your partner, with your
team, all the internal things,
and then the client
folder as the name says,
all the interactions where
you're gonna have meetings
with your clients.
Next you will have a folder
for the initial data requests
and here not on every project,
but in many projects
before you actually start,
you will submit a list of
data that you ask the client
to prepare to make sure
that once you're there,
once you're working on the
client that you already have,
at least most of the things you need
to enable you to hit the ground running.
This is often important base data
that the whole team needs access to.
So you make sure that you
have this neatly collected
in this overarching folder.
Next you will have a folder each
for the key work streams
or modules of your project.
Usually when you set up a project,
you divide it into different subs streams,
into different modules,
into different work streams.
And then often you assign each associate
to one of these modules.
In this specific example,
you work for different
business units of the clients.
So for an energy business unit,
for an automotive business unit
and for an advanced
industries business unit,
these folders will be owned
by the associates of your team working
on the individual modules,
and this is where all the module specific
where all the work stream
specific content sits
for your project.
Next you will have some folders
for the big over arching analysis
that you are doing for some
work stream overarching,
some module overarching topics
that your team is working on.
In this specific example,
there was an employee survey
where apparently the employees
of the clients were surveyed.
In this folder you could
now organize the survey
and where you could then
save all the survey results.
In addition it that seem to have happened
an overarching benchmark
where different functions
of the client were benchmarked.
And again, then you can
set up a folder like this
where you organize it.
Next you have a folder with
input from your research team.
And first of all,
notice on all the first number
of this folder is a nine.
So by giving it a nine,
you make sure that it
always stays at the bottom
of your folder structure.
So you do this
to keep these a bit less important folders
always at the bottom to not
mess up the whole order.
So in such a research input folder
you can collect all the inputs
that you get from your research team.
So many large consulting firms,
you will have back offices
that help you to do some research.
Such a folder would be the place
where you organize all this.
Then you might have a
folder for old documents,
maybe there was already a
project going on before you,
and now you just take all the data
and just put it in one folder.
So you have it available
if you still need needed at
some point in the future.
And then finally you
would often use a folder
for finding the deliverables
where you then over time organize
or the final documents
that you would hand over to the client
at the very end of your project.
So lets now go one level
deeper on the meeting folders,
because these are indeed some folders
that are usually heavily used,
and it's quite important
to have a solid order here.
The first thought is here
that every meeting you have
should be documented in these folders.
So if you wonder, okay,
what document did I show two weeks ago?
When I sat together with this guy,
you should always be able to go back
in your folder structure
and find the very specific document
that then you wanna pull out.
And what I learned,
and what I can really recommend you
is to always then make the folders start
with the date when the
meeting actually took place.
And here again, make sure
that you start with the year,
then the month, and then the day,
because this makes sure
that if you order them
that the meetings will always
show up chronologically
as they actually took place.
And then often it makes sense to record
what type of meeting it is.
And often also with whom
you had the meetings.
For the internal meeting
folder this can for instance,
be a team kickoff, the team offsite,
maybe some meetings or calls
you had with partners of yours
as this list of folders can easily grow
and can get quite large at some point,
then it can often make sense
than just to put together
all the meetings in one month
or a monthly folder.
So at some point
you can just drag all
the meetings in July,
into a July folder
all the meetings in August
and into an August folder.
And then you just have
all the detailed list
just for the current month.
Where then you might need
to more granually log into the meetings.
For the clients it's very similar.
You might typically have draw fixes.
You might have steer cross.
You might have other
client meetings like that.
If you're interested to learn more,
of how such a typical work week
in the life of an MBB
consultant looks like
also check out the video
that I will insert here somewhere
about to better understand
how exactly these meetings would play out
during a typical work week.
Now, another little best practice tip
that I wanna give you,
is now to organize the documents
within these specific meeting folders.
So if you worked together on
a team on such a document of
and then this folder can
easily look like this, right?
So how a lot of versions
and often if you work on such documents
like the big steer
documents over some time
with your team,
the list of documents can easily
look like a mess like this.
So with lots of different versions,
lots of different situations.
And at some point it
can get super difficult
for somebody looking at it to understand
what now really the latest version is
now especially if you put yourself
into the shoes of for instance, a partner,
he just wants to access the drive,
just go into the meeting folder
and just quickly pull
out the latest version
of the steer document that
actually was shown, right?
Just to look something up.
And for him now if he
sees something like this,
this is really a nightmare
because he doesn't know what
now the latest version was,
and he pretty much needs to
always call up the team and ask,
"Hey guys, and what is
not the latest version.
I don't understand
anything at all anymore.
So here it's a best practice then
to have such an old folder,
but then you drag all
the older versions in
and make sure that in the meetings folder
you really only have the latest
version of your documents,
the latest, and then
hopefully final version
that then everybody knows,
okay, this is really the
document that we need to look at.
Another little best practice is also
to clearly label the documents
by the status of the release.
So if you send out a
document to the client
and distinctly save it as a V sent
or something related
you can present the document,
distinctly save it as a V presented.
Or there may be a few
make changes afterwards,
save it as a V final,
but this will enable you,
if they really wanna know, okay,
what was the version that I sent out?
What was the version
that I really presented?
with some last changes?
And maybe even that after the meeting,
that all of this is always
clearly labeled, clearly saved.
This can really save you
some significant headache
If then later somebody asks you
about a specific version
that you're just not able
to understand anymore.
Which of the version
numbers it was, right?
So clearly always save
it with these labels.
You will really thank me in
the long term, if you do that.
So that's it guys.
These are my best practices.
So I believe you should organize
and structure your project.
And what for sure is the best practice
in large MBB consulting firms.
Hope you found this insightful.
And if you have any more questions,
feel free to leave me a comment
below in the comment section
as always, I will do my very best
to answer every single one.
If you took any value
out of this video at all,
please, destroy the like button
for the YouTube algorithm
and also subscribe to my
channel for even more content.
I release weekly videos every Saturday.
So subscribe to stay up to date.
If you want to see even more from me,
follow me on my Instagram.
My handle is @firmlearning.
And I also have a mailing list.
If you wanna sign up for that,
there's a link in the video description.
For access to some more great
perks that only members get,
sign up as a member.
There's a join button next
to the subscription button
and also in the video description.
And yes, you will get access
to some member only perks.
Thank you for watching and your support.
This really means the world to me.
Thank you guys.
I'm Heinrich from Firm Learning
and see you again next Saturday.
Bye.